[Musik]
corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
mein heutiger gast ist der bonner
virologe professor hendrik strikt
angesichts explodierender fallzahlen
lautet unser thema diesmal verlieren wir
die kontrolle und wir wollen darüber
reden was wir von aids für die krone
krise lernen können herzlich willkommen
schönen guten abend ja wir gehen wir mal
mit der aktuellen situation exponentiell
steigende infektionszahlen deutlich
höher als im frühjahr haben wir die
kontrolle schon verloren
nun ich glaube alle haben damit
gerechnet dass zum herbst und winter die
zahlen nach oben gehen werden und wir
dürfen uns nicht von den zahlen vom
frühjahr verleiten lassen
da wir damals sehr viel weniger getestet
haben und sehr viel schlechter
aufgestellt gewesen sind wichtig ist es
in meinen augen gerade dass wir die
schützen und die besser schützen um die
es eigentlich geht nimmt die
risikogruppen in altenheimen pflegeheime
aber auch die die zu hause wohnen und
vielleicht ein höheres risiko haben so
dass wir unsere ressourcen auch darauf
mehr konzentrieren dass die geschützt
werden und nicht nur auf die
infektionszahlen zuschauen wie könnte
man das denn das machen die
risikopatienten schützen
nun man kann meinen in altenheimen und
pflegeheim zum beispiel sehr viel mehr
testen man kann zb zweimal dreimal in
der woche die das personal also auch das
reinigungspersonal testen man kann ffp
zwei masten für besucher verpflichtend
machen oder auch personal
man kann aber auch nachbarschaftshilfen
aufbauen und das gestützt von den
regierungen auch landesregierungen
aufbauen dass man versorgung vom
nachbarn also für lebensmittel oder
anderen dingen aufbaut also dass
bereitstellt aber auch tests zu hause
ermöglicht das sind alles gedanken die
man konkretisieren sollte und dafür
haben wir den sommer bisher noch nicht
genug genutzt hat man denn das irgendwo
auf der welt schon mal geschafft die
risikogruppen zu isolieren zu schützen
ohne sie völlig abzuschotten von der
welt wie in ein gefängnis nein also dass
das hat man natürlich
ich geschafft weil es so eine situation
wie wir sie jetzt haben ja auch noch
nicht gab aber es geht ja eigentlich
darum sie nicht weg zu sperren nicht zu
isolieren sondern ein
trotzdem besucher zu ermöglichen indem
man zum beispiel am eingang abstriche
macht und die menschen am eingang testet
bevor sie ihre verwandten im krankenhaus
besuchen
dazu bräuchte man die schnelltests die
jetzt auf den markt kommt sie haben
gesagt es ist falsch immer nur auf die
fallzahlen zu blicken oder gar zustand
was wäre denn die alternative
ja ich plädiere wirklich dafür dass wir
uns nicht von den infektionszahlen
alleine leiten lassen sondern auch die
anzahl der tests die stationäre belegung
und die intensivmedizinische belegung in
unsere überlegungen mit einbeziehen also
nicht nur infektions sein sondern vier
faktoren die wir mit einschließen und
darauf basieren schwellenwerte
definieren an denen wir uns auch richten
können und das heißt eine ampel zb
farblich darstellen
das gibt uns die möglichkeit zum einen
besser das infektionsgeschehen
einzuschätzen ob vielleicht die
kapazitätsgrenze zum beispiel
krankenhäusern erreicht wird aber auch
zum anderen zu verstehen die sich das
infektionsgeschehen im allgemeinen also
auch in der größeren bevölkerung verhält
also verstehe ich das richtig da wären
steigende infektionszahlen vielleicht
gar nicht so schlimm und würden nicht zu
einer roten ampel film so lange ich noch
genügend intensivbetten habe ja aber vor
allem die stationäre belegung also gar
nicht die intensivmedizinische belegung
weil das wäre zu spät
die nur infektionszahlen bären zu wenig
daher ist es die kombination dieser
faktoren die man sich anschauen muss
weil um das einfach mal zu sagen ich
würde mir mehr sorgen machen wenn es
einen ausbruch in einem altersheim geben
und mit einem schlag 30 menschen
stationär behandelt werden müssen aber
im vergleich
ja junge menschen irgendwie 100 200
junge menschen infiziert werden aber die
kaum symptome hatten und die stationäre
belebung leer wäre
lasst uns mal reden über die
sterblichkeit im frühjahr sind je nach
land unterschiedlich zwischen fünf und
zehn prozent der infizierten oder besser
gesagt der positiv getesteten gestorben
inzwischen ist die sogenannte infektions
sterblichkeit viel viel niedriger woran
liegt das denn und wie hoch ist
eigentlich diese infektion sterblichkeit
in deutschland nun man muss
unterscheiden ob es jetzt die fall
sterblichkeit oder infektions
sterblichkeit ist und am anfang haben
wir nur die daten gehabt von der fall
sterblichkeit also jeder positiv
getestete mensch im vergleich dazu also
wie viele menschen positiv getestet
wurden und wie viele von den positiv
getesteten gestorben sind
da wurde die sogenannte dunkelziffer
nicht mit einbezogen also von denen man
nicht wusste dass sie infiziert waren
wir haben in heinsberg also in der
unserer studie die infektions tätigkeit
bestimmt da gibt es sehr viele weitere
studien die das mittlerweile gemacht
haben
rund 61 studien weltweit und da rechnet
man mit einer infektion steuer
sterblichkeit die natürlich einen großen
fehler bereich hat aber um die von 0,1
bis 0,6 0,9 prozent wir hatten damals
0,37 oder 0,36 beschrieben und es wird
sich in diesem bereich verhalten damit
lässt sich aber dass wir uns einordnen
nämlich dass es weitaus gefährlicher ist
als eine normale grippe
aber wir es auch nicht überdramatisieren
sollten und es nicht in diesem bereich
von 1 5% oder ähnliches weg von 1000
infizierten werden am ende drei oder
vier sterben wie wäre es denn bei grippe
sterben davon 1000 infizierten dass das
kann man eben sehr schwer sagen weil so
eine studie in der artist noch nicht
durchgeführt worden richtig für die
grippe und je man muss auch bedenken
dass wir jedes jahr eigentlich eine
andere krippe haben also manchmal auch
mal die gleiche aber meistens ist es
doch eine andere saisonale grippe aber
wir gehen von einer infektion
sterblichkeit dort aus von 0,09 prozent
also deutlich niedriger sagen wir jetzt
mal 0 1
weil es einfacher ist eine von tausend
würde sterben bei corona drei bis vier
affen 1000 das ist aber wie gesagt
schwer einzuordnen weil man so genau wie
wir auf das neue virus jetzt schauen auf
die grippe eigentlich noch gar nicht
geschaut haben so eine frage werde ich
noch gern ihre meinungen hören
ärztepräsident reinhardt hat sehr
starken zweifel geübt geäußert an der
sinnhaftigkeit von masken hat er recht
nein also masken wirken vor allem wenn
man die distanz nicht einhalten kann
dann hilft es einen selber aber auch vor
allem den anderen wenn man eine maske
trägt um übertragung zu vermeiden was
ich war wo ich denke wurden die maske
nicht sinnvoll ist ist draußen im freien
wo man zum einen die luft hat wo auch
ihre sohle gar nicht entstehen können
und zum anderen wo man eigentlich sehr
viel eher auf abstand hält
es könnte noch sein dass es noch monate
vielleicht sogar jahre dauert bis ein
impfstoff rettet wie kann jetzt eine
gesellschaft mit einer epidemie leben
die sie nicht besiegen kann ohne diese
gesellschaft auf dauer einzustellen da
lohnt vielleicht ein blick auf die
geschichte von aids was können wir denn
daraus lernen
ja es gibt wirklich viele parallelen zur
hiv pandemie ist es übrigens eine
pandemie die immer noch stattfindet also
die nicht beendet wurde und der anfang
bei dieser pandemie war sehr ähnlich
nämlich das unheimlich viel angst
herrschte vor dem virus und man auch
sehr drakonische maßnahmen diskutiert
hat wie zum beispiel alle infizierten zu
internieren
auch die stigmatisierung von infizierten
ist ja immer noch ein großes thema das
ihr bei corona sehen aber jetzt auch und
bei hiv schon über 30 jahre eigentlich
miterleben dass wichtige was ich finde
was man daraus lernen kann ist dass die
hiv pandemie kontrolliert wurde zum teil
durch ebeling strategien damit meine ich
dass man den menschen maßnahmen an die
hand gegeben hat wie jeder für sich
selber
eigenverantwortung übernehmen kann
selber auf seine mitmenschen und auf
sich achtgeben kann um das virus nicht
weiter zu tragen und das sind maßnahmen
wo man weiß da kann man sehr viele jahre
mit klarkommen kann das auch eine
verbreitung verhindern ohne dass man zu
dollar einschnitte ins leben macht ja da
würde ich gern noch ein bisschen tiefer
einsteigen das sind ja auch sehr
drastische maßnahmen besprochen so
beginnen wurden zu beginn dieser
epidemie sie haben es gesagt die
isolierung von infizierten mann hat über
sport verbote gesprochen man hat verbot
von prostitution und einschläge gegen
klubs diskutiert am ende ist das jetzt
alles vom tisch geblieben ist die
empfehlung kondome zu benutzen
was kann man von dem denn übertragen auf
die corona in petra also die das
phänomen ist ein gutes beispiel für
solche nebeling strategien weil man den
menschen oder den risikopersonen an die
hand gegeben hat hier ihr könnt euch
selber schützen durch relativ einfache
maßnahmen noch besser man hat den
kondome frei zur verfügung gestellt so
dass das vorhandensein von kondomen und
die aufmerksamkeit machen durch große
kampagnen damals also jeder erinnert
sich an rieter was kosten die kondome
die werbespots wurde erreicht dass
menschen von sich aus sicher und andere
geschützt haben und das ist eben auch im
übertragenen sinne was wir für corona
will das jetzt heißen die maske mehr
sexy machen ja zum beispiel die maske
mehr als sexy machen aber auch dass es
gesellschaftlich gewollt ist die maske
zu tragen das ist nicht etwas ist was
man verpflichtend tragen muss sondern
eigentlich das geführt ich mache das aus
der eigenverantwortung und aus der
achtsamkeit dem anderen gegenüber
wenn man immer nur droht und warnt oder
sogar strafen belegen will mit einem
nicht maske tragen dann kommt man eher
in an einem punkt am anfang wirkt es
kommt man aber an einem punkt wo dann
eher das rebellische dann auch auskommt
bei jeder pandemie sucht man schuldige
jetzt bei der korona krise sind es
jugendliche partygänger muslimische
hochzeiten reiserückkehrer bei aids
bestand ja die wirklich berechtigt die
gefahr dass auf dauer homosexuelle
stigmatisiert werden
ich weiß nicht wie sie das einschätzen
hat man das verhindern können und wenn
ja wie hat man das geschafft
also es ist bei hiv und aids immer noch
so dass das eine deutliche
stigmatisierung ist die erkrankung zu
haben
ein hiv positiver ist zb wenn er gut
behandelt ist nicht mehr infektiös er
kann das virus nicht mehr weitergeben
aber er wird immer noch eher als gefahr
eingeschätzt also in vielen bereichen
man spricht dann zb von zero sorting
dass die nicht mehr als
geschlechtspartner anerkannt werden oder
nicht mehr gewollt werden und diese
stigmatisierung die zieht sich da
eigentlich dauerhaft durch und die
aktivisten aber auch ärzte und
wissenschaftler arbeiten immer noch
dagegen an um diese stigmatisierung als
abzubauen
bei corona hatten wir am anfang die
stigmatisierung mit den asiaten dann das
dass asiaten generell gesehen wurden als
jemand die das virus bringen würden dann
hat man es dann gab es den schwenk zu
den heinsberger gütersloh autos wurden
zerkratzt reifen zerstochen und jetzt
sind es die jugendlichen partygänger und
oder und oder große hochzeiten im
arabischen raum ein game changer der
punkte alles verändert hat bei aids war
die entwicklung von arzneimitteln die
die krankheit inzwischen mehr als
erträglich macht wie ist das wenn man
heute aids infiziert ist was bedeutet
das nun wenn man heute sich mit hiv
infiziert und das früh erkannt wird
darum ist ein früher hiv-test auch wie
stich dann und das gut behandelt wird
dann ist die lebenserwartung genauso wie
jemand der hiv negativ ist das hängt
natürlich vom lebensstil ab aber es gibt
da eigentlich keinen großen unterschied
wäre es dann auch sinnvoll sich jetzt in
der kur oder krise nicht immer nur auf
die entwicklung von impfstoffen zu
konzentrieren sondern zu sagen
vielleicht ist es ja viel viel erfolg
versprechend da ein arzneimittel das
heilt oder mit zumindest die krankheit
lindert zu entwickeln
also wie gesagt es kann sein dass ein
impfstoff kommen wird das will ich gar
nicht außer frage stellen aber wir
können es einfach nicht seriös
vorhersagen
worauf ich ein bisschen die hoffnung
setze ist das dass diese monoklonalen
antikörper dass zum beispiel das
regeneron was auch präsident amt
bekommen hat dass das in der behandlung
der schwerstkranken wirklich gut
funktionieren wird und das haben die
klinischen studien bisher auch gezeigt
so dass er die sterblichkeitsrate also
die infektion sterblichkeitsraten noch
weiter senken können und ist das risiko
einer erkrankung und auch einen schweren
verlauf noch weiter gesenkt wird zum
ende noch eine frage zur rolle der
experten bei uns in deutschland gibt's
professor thorsten montgomery lauterbach
die mannen waren und drohen wir
verlieren die kontrolle
sie sieht dagegen wirken viel viel
ruhiger gelassener woran liegt das
ja also ich glaube ist das kommt aus
verschiedenen richtungen einmal habe ich
sehr viele infizierte gesehen und ich
weiß was das virus für viele menschen
bedeutet wenn sie sich infizieren und
das hat mich auch gelehrt einzuschätzen
die gefahr für die gesellschaft aber
auch für jeden einzelnen so dass das
zwar ein risiko da ist was aber
einschätzbar ist und für den einzelnen
das risiko ein langzeit folgen zu haben
sehr geringes aber dass es die
ja die fallstricke der statistik dass
trotzdem auch für jeden ein schweres
risiko bestehen kann
daher denke ich gekommen besser durch
die pandemie wenn wir souveränität
zeigen und auch jeder souverän wird mit
dem umgang mit dem virus anstatt dass
sich jener einschließt weil wir müssen
auch an die anderen gefahren denken die
eben durch andere erkrankungen entstehen
können professor strikt bei corinna
nachgehakt herzlichen dank wir liebe
zuschauern liebe zuschauer wir liefern
in den letzten stand der wissenschaft
kuroda nachgehakt regelmäßig im phoenix
programm und jederzeit abrufbar auf
unserer homepage in der ard mediathek
und auf youtube bleib gesund